Please welcome my enemy Will Ferrell.
How are you, Will?
I'm good.
No one's applauding,
Will, there's no audience.
No, Will, no, there's no.
I'm just so used to doing
that for talk show appearances
that it's hard to break that habit.
Yeah, do you miss the
laughter in quarantine?
Oh my god, you know what?
I've trained my children to act like
a room full of sitcom writers,
that everything I say,
they just go (laughs)
Yeah.
But the weird thing is
they're not saying things
like "I wrote that, wrote that line."
(laughs)
I wrote, that's mine, that's mine.
Uh-huh, I want to say you um,
you look very handsome, I
like your hair in quarantine.
You look good, your hair's getting,
it's a nice uh, very puffy,
your hair, I didn't realize.
Yeah, I can get a lot
of volume very quickly
if it's not maintained,
and uh, I don't know,
there's no reason to cut it.
Yeah, no, these are strange
times, to say the least.
Do you have anyone in your family
that you would trust
with cutting your hair?
Here's the thing, no,
I would not trust anyone to cut my hair,
but I kinda like just letting it go.
You know, the Conan pompadour.
Sure, classic.
Classic.
Thanks, it has collapsed
under the weight of
the length of the hair,
and now I'm just letting it go.
You're almost unrecognizable.
Yeah, you like that?
Without the pomp.
Can you hear a truck backing
up in the background?
Nope.
Oh, then I probably shouldn't
have called attention to it.
It's incredibly loud here at the theater.
We're shooting at the Largo Theater,
I know you've appeared here many times.
I am having a whole
truckload of Omaha Steaks
though delivered to you and your crew.
(laughs)
Maybe that's what that is.
That may be the truck.
Why did you have them delivered
when you knew we'd be
interviewed? That seems awkward.
You know what, I didn't remember exactly,
I just said, you know,
they have those windows,
they said any time from one to four, so.
(laughs)
Is that up to me?
No, no, I uh, are you doing okay?
Is that your office right there?
That looks like the office that a manager
would have at a construction site.
What's happening there,
it really does look like.
It's funny you should say that,
I am in one of those mini trailers
that you'd see on a construction site.
[Conan] Uh-huh, that's
what it looks like, yeah.
With no windows, just a weird
door and bad wood paneling.
Yeah, this is a little off-shoot,
yeah, a little office here.
Yeah, would you tell me,
would you be honest with me,
if during this period of
time, you were working
at a construction, oh what's that?
Oh Network, that's a great movie.
I still gotta watch Network,
so that's on my to-do list.
(laughs)
That's why you have,
you had a small trailer
built on your property
so you could watch the movie Network?
Network and uh, what else we got here?
Oh, a bootleg of A Face In The Crowd.
Okay listen to me, listen to me,
there's something, Will.
I got a lot of bootlegs.
There's something called streaming.
You could stream all of this.
No, no, no, no.
(Conan laughs)
I like the old-fashioned DVD.
Okay well, I think that's
a good use of your time,
be in a small shack watching old movies
in and out-dated format,
and I congratulate you.